[Music]
spend the extra money to do something
crazy that everybody wants to take a
photo with you see where I'm going this
portion is like with me so I think this
is when you need to get selfish like
you'd ask your question
hiring is guessing firing is know like
you got to go fast that's how you get
[ __ ] done that's in figure stuff out
this is the television and the
television is the radio so forties
[ __ ] what's on your mind what
can I answer how do you make
determinations on where and how you
spend your time knowing how valuable and
how limited your time is um oh I'm
really happy you're asking this question
because if you can internalize what I'm
about to say you will not believe what
it's about to do for you the answer is
the ability to have to judge myself by
you know how a lot of times there's a
lot of people in there's a really dirty
secret in the strategy world of like
Dana Mackenzie where if you really get
them drunk they admit that the actions
lead to the strategy not the other way
around that's my answer to you how I
make decisions and then I tried to look
at my calendar the week ahead and see if
any decisions I made four weeks earlier
that made me think this was a good use
of time am i able to move something cut
something down I'm extremely thoughtful
about cutting times and meetings so one
of the things I think that really make
me successful is understanding a 7
minute meeting is real and not just
making it a 30 minute meeting but the
real reason is cuz I don't overthink it
I'm operating my business a minute how
do I decide between going to dinner with
Kevin Hart because I can and I want to
build top of the funnel brand or do I go
take a mid-level client that I'm trying
to build a relationship with it's you
know you ask every normal person it
seems like those aren't super close but
I can touch the pulse and be like I'm
going I like four more times in the next
three months you know the biggest
mistakes I make are the ones of missed
opportunities of the things by being
crippled by opportunity when you
actually level that all up my friend
it really is liberating
you will never even come close to making
the right decision I mean it you just
don't know what the alternative would be
people think it there's a right answer
you as an operator of your business make
the right call that feels right at that
moment and just move and people spend
all this time and money I'm trying to
think that there's a proper answer I
play on the extremes
I spend as much time as possible in the
things that are showing me the most
offense right however you're doing your
customer acquisition to get to a Hondo
on a product like that like whether it's
Facebook whether it's brand whether and
then I spend the amount of time on my
biggest vulnerability you know putting
my finger in the holes to make sure the
boat doesn't sink and building a bigger
[ __ ] boat and nothing in the middle
and knowing that I'm making that
judgment at all times and the second I
get new data a week later I might have
to completely change what I thought was
right the week before it's also why I
spent a ton of time with my employees
the reason I'm an HR driven CEO is if
you really understand this both your
biggest growth and your biggest
vulnerabilities are actually your own
team so I think it's a lack of it starts
with the ability not to over judge
yourself because that is the liberator
of the model I just broke down for you
but even even though even though items
that you may have scheduled out for
weeks in advance you still sit down the
beginning of that week to reevaluate at
our best which I don't do all the time
my admins and I are doing some sort of
version of an audit on Friday mm-hmm
because they get it you find yourself in
that paralysis of where are you spending
your time on the most valuable
activities I don't think that way and
nobody I mean listen I'm in the mix for
top busy people I'm in the conversation
you know I go hard to 15 hours a day
I do seven-minute meetings I'm [ __ ]
in the conversation and I easily spend
25% of my day on things that end up
being dumb [ __ ]
that is where the speed comes in got it
if I if I spend time looking back at my
calendar for the last month
I'd be devastatingly sad people judge
themselves you're the if you're an
operator and you're in the mix on your
business you made the best decision you
could at that moment with the data that
you had the end is was it to go to a CRO
Bruce meaning or was it to go meet a
supplier of milk or to go meet an
influencer who was destined to be the
one that broke you out all three sounds
bright to me
and they all could end up being right or
could end up being wrong my thing is if
you go super fast and go super hard and
super efficient you might be able do all
three if you're not spending half your
time judging yourself if you're getting
it right got it
you see where I'm going you wouldn't be
here maybe maybe that's what you needed
today like you would have this whole day
back just even in the month there's no
way I do this that's not how I learned
now you may learn this way but there's
never a chance in hell that I'd ever be
at afford ease because I learned from so
much doing that's why my data is so
clean it's why I'm an innovator
it's why I'm fast it's why a lot of good
things happen for me because I realized
just the doing is actually more
efficient than the thinking about it
somebody said something really smart
funny to me once and it was like the dig
of this version and it's a really funny
conversation he was talking about being
her media at the time this was maybe
five or six years ago said you know Gary
I got to tell you I love your company
but I gotta take a little bit of a knock
on you he was trying to set it up I'm
like okay what is it he goes if I was
sitting in this room and you guys were
standing outside and I said vaynermedia
I need you to sit right next to me I
know you guys would do it he goes where
I'm where I think you need to be more
thoughtful Gary is I have a feeling
though that you might run through that
glass panel and sit with us when you
could have just opened the [ __ ] door
and I said yeah but which one was cooler
you know and so and so the answer to
that is like I think what you know what
that gentleman didn't understand
and in his analogy as a critique was he
was trying to have an intellectual
conversation about something that it's
all of our businesses will be super fun
to talk about in a Harvard Business
study or around a campfire in 40 years
with our grandkids when we can
pontificate and but but we're operating
right now that got it it will work you
can't imagine how much mine time is
actually being wasted if you're thinking
about that question it's crippling I
mean it I have a lot of empathy for it
and I'm really like a that's why you
know I don't normally pause before my
answer I was super pumped you asked that
because it's one of the biggest answers
I've got in my repertoire and if I can
come you know cuz I'm a good
communicator if this is the moment and
you get momentum on this you will
[ __ ] you will you'll be back in here
and be like it was just that I didn't
realize how much that was affecting me
and that makes you that faster then all
of a sudden you can see where this goes
right all of a sudden because you know
you're doing this thing that's foreign
to you [ __ ] Gary said let me try this
week all of a sudden you're like [ __ ]
but I want to get this up there and all
of a sudden that 30-minute meeting
becomes 16 all of a sudden that meaning
you just cancel and you do it the next
day you call you make you turn it into a
call on the way there you you you know
I'm the manifestation at this point of
being in my prime of something I've now
done for 22 years I'm now tomorrow I
turn 40 for so I'm right there 22 years
of not running a good business and 22
years of now running businesses
completely always and now I'm in you
know in this state where like I feel
really good you know unstoppable because
it's like there's you're just at the
extreme version of it's like working out
every day for 20 you're at you're in a
different place I'm in a real crescendo
of like this model and it really works
it's practical no because everyone else
is doing it for me you know what I mean
we just can't you know really do think
business is much more like sport you
know it's really funny I used to always
think that it always made sense that I
like both now now I hear things back to
being in the prime you
here things of like a quarterback saying
you know I just got to go to the next
play I know I threw two pics in a row
and and he's right and look you know I
used to hear it as a fan like [ __ ] you
you [ __ ] threw picks up pissed you
know like I thought about now I'm like
that's exactly right like I can make
seven bad this as long as I don't put us
out of business no really I really it's
that binary it's a funny thing to say
but to your point and to like mine as
long as I to put us out of business I'm
like yeah like I hate that I made that
call you know I prefer not to
I wish it didn't happen but it did and
spending I've learned from it I don't
need to like be myself up to learn from
it I learned from it I understand that I
over what I over leveraged our ice cream
business to too much retail and gave
them too much leverage and now when they
kicked me out I'm in trouble and I
should have built my director consumer
business right it's not super
complicated yeah and speed becomes your
ally when you're able to move bro and
you'll love this one thing that business
and [ __ ] sports share that nobody
talks about speed over everything
there's a reason the Chiefs are good
right now they figured it out draft
speed it's not teachable to your point
that you find often you're in situations
where you have to make it you have to
make snap decisions I can choose to do
this or I can choose to do that and
you're only basically on the video on
the available data correct I don't even
need to do any homework that's why I'm
always improv I'm [ __ ] operating my
business I can make a decision right now
it's the lack of judgment right you see
where that see how that's kind of frothy
but you're like oh right that makes
sense because if you choose and then it
was super obvious six months later that
you should have went triple retail
instead of doing Diet milk on you know
making up [ __ ] now well well okay but
like I didn't look like what like I
don't I don't think I think people think
they're gonna do some property value
process when you're when you're when
you're dealing with the actual consumer
they're moving as fast as you are
not with me that's why I'm win right
like I feel like I'm with them I'm day
trading my decisions are in day trade
mode and people think that they're they
they over value what they were taught in
school the process you know any more
decisions you can make when you're not
in the process of one and then what ends
up happening is you net win because that
mistake you made was offset by for other
good decisions you made it's so cool to
like even like like I'm listening to
myself almost right now and I'm like God
it makes so much [ __ ] sense
but it speaks to why entrepreneurship is
hard and talent oriented it is truly a
skill like there's a very big difference
between being an entrepreneur and being
an operator and some entrepreneurs can
be operators and they tend to do well
and some people could be operators and
they build very nice businesses but
getting good at those two things and the
entrepreneurial part is where the real
hyper upside actually lives the
operating part is commoditized it's a
more teachable skill than leaning into
intuition leaning into listening to the
unconsumed listen leaning into you know
nuances of innovation being enjoying
risk not being fearful I think I think
that what I just talked about is being
the Chiefs and I think most people are
trying to build the 85 Bears people are
defense oriented which is great both
both can be good right in the way that I
just said it but like there are way more
teams that have won because they were
the best offense defense wins
championships is a very very misleading
very misleading statement of a Hall of
Fame defensive lineman or linebackers
that disrupt offense sure go ahead
we have enough time to battle you if
you've got something to pin your tongue
complete please feel free what are
things I'm really impressed by is
the the Vayner X umbrella right you've
got different distinct businesses we met
today different folks across those very
engine what what's driving that
structure as opposed to okay it's the
speed you can move Zack I you know I'm
tired of paying a big Commission on my
speaking fee the kid who's been doing it
for nine years is becoming a grown-up I
really genuinely like him I'm building
one massive communications framework
part of communications is humans that
communicate we should start a speaking
Bureau that's the success I don't talk
about Boehner experience or we've been
Vayner live we I've had two failed
attempts now at doing event marketing I
know what's with them I love losing as
much as I love the Sasha group is as
much as I love Vayner live and Vayner
experience because I know the fifth time
I'm gonna get it because live events
matter in today's world definitely
matters in your world its place to think
about so like you know so yes but where
my team thinks I move slow is it might
not manifest in as quickly as about it's
because I haven't decided that's not
working I'm okay being down 31 nothing
at halftime if I truly believe I'm gonna
win 35 31 as you can imagine if you've
got executives consumers business
partners they're like you're down 31
nothing you know and I'm like mm-hmm but
I was at the Monday night miracle we
were down 32 7 with 10 minutes left we
won it was sure was I wish social media
existed so I can prove I was there
because every Jeff a.m. claims they were
there but there was only [ __ ] 4,000
people there so you know I think that uh
I do
I do but that's a singular decision by
me not my experts rallying around but
when my experts rally around and I hold
the line and the final comes in 48 to 17
I look at them and say I was wrong so if
you're gonna do it to keep credibility
with your teammates you have to
acknowledge when you're wrong so yes I
do
and sometimes that goes the other way
you know sometime I mean there's a story
I reference a lot of hiring somebody and
literally knowing within 24 hours of
them being in the building that I [ __ ]
up big that's fine yeah so you know we
met with Claude today yes and she's
really reinforced the heart the culture
what do you look for when you're hiring
particular your top talent that focus
reporting to you the ones that are the
emerging talent in that top okay
humility the big one I'm so confident
and I love people so much that the great
mistake I've made over the last decade
which I think I'm just back to being in
your prime I think I'm just on the cusp
of finally fixing was I was attracted to
people that were insecure because I
wanted to help them so the real answer
is people that are deeply confident in
who they are
which then manifests in very good
behavior if you're wildly confident
you're actually extremely humble as I've
got to know myself better of like why
are we so weird like it so much
conviction and confidence but like
really like if you really get to the
people close like like humility is
absolutely my superpower and so I'm
starting to look for more it's all
emotional intelligence it's already
confident are you kind are you capable
and I'm doing a better and better job of
really communicating to people like my
big thing to people is like look
everybody is saying in today's world
what I'm saying so you're gonna think
I'm kind of joking and you're gonna be
able to get away with being a dick I'm
like I'm saving you a lot of time you
will be fired if you're not good to the
other boys and girls do have the
capability of being the bigger girl or
guy in every situation every time you're
100% right yet you still roll with
empathy and compassion and then you can
come to me and be like Karen's a
[ __ ] can we fix this but to them so
you don't rock the boat communication
capabilities are you are you the kind of
person that when the going gets rough
lashes out don't join here because I'm
the kind of person when the going gets
rough I mean my [ __ ]
and happiest and kindest state I'm a
wartime general so I'm trying to
communicate those virtues the skill is a
commodity skills a commodity so the past
year we grow worse yes I part of it so
it's so fun to talk about what I talk
about because I know it's a 100 percent
right because I've already lived it I'm
never guessing so it makes me happy like
you know this people don't call me on my
bluff like that's what you guys actually
did you actually just did it like
tomorrow I'm putting out this deck the
whole thing I'm alluding to on my social
like gift for everybody we're putting
out a Jason how big of a deck is it
putting on a 250 page deck that we put
like like it probably I don't even want
to it probably cost me a hundred
thousand dollars to like make if I
looked at all the hours that went it
like I don't want to look it's going to
be it's almost like if I bap to idna its
entitled how to make sixty what's the
final number fifty it's nothing I didn't
let them make it round I think it's 63
now it's basically how to make 63 pieces
of content in a day but for real like
you know I have that Gary beep content
pyramid which was a great great deck and
like everybody lost their mind this is
like on some 301 level [ __ ] I'm so
pumped for tomorrow anyway nonetheless
go ahead yeah so we're actually not
really stuck on anything cuz I'm good I
think the answer a lot of just doing
more yep put it all back into so what
can answer so a couple things least you
know we made over a thousand post but
that was me in heaven yep and now it's
the time to start building tongue a
little bit like what you have been going
on is absolutely because we spell the
time to dirt I'm like running through
video guys like crazy
why what's your intuition but like let's
play let's play cuz take on the
accountability instead of a big part
that is like good this is by the way
that little moment is everything if you
want to know actually why I think I'll
buy the New York Jets it was that 45
seconds the world says cuz nobody wants
to work and I say cuz my hiring sucks
and I love you for going there quickly
now you start hacking you've got to be
way more upfront of the expectations
like when I hired when I are my team and
do knows this it's like you're gonna do
what I did
you're gonna eat dirt this is terrible
my kind of story do you oh yeah
give me one give me one here I always
unpaid eight months I paid Warner
dollars a month to commute
it's a veiner I got on a train from the
beach in New Jersey and it took me 2
hours and 45 minutes door to door for
six months and that was just like up for
an expectation then I got her room with
him and he said give me 16 more months
they'll be exactly where I want you to
make and I gave him a 16 months and like
you know that was the first three years
of my career pretty much we used to
actually do a lot more gauntlet types of
telogen because we don't have any money
so we're I guess work for freaks that's
exactly right so like I think one of the
things you need to think about this is
where I get caught - and I say to myself
is when you didn't have anything to
offer it kind of worked out because
almost the expectation upfront was a
better communication where you have a
little fluff now you can get caught and
this is so like cliche I think you have
to have a to your point I think you
should almost probably make a video
that's like funny and cool and I'm brand
that like completely communicates if you
want to do video for us like this is
what it's about I got to make the
promise more upfront it's on us
I used to fire people and even during
next time he knows this there's people
here that I did so well by who don't
like me because I didn't communicate
well enough that they weren't doing you
the job so they were flabbergasted when
they got fired and that's the post game
version of what you guys have in the
pregame you need to over communicate
expectation like over communicate you
know and not do the we walk 15 feet in
snow for four miles like the thing that
we all do like I [ __ ] like these kids
don't like even your kids and you like
these kids don't want to work you know
like that's not the actual truth it's
that you painted the wrong picture and
so another thing we have is so we have
like a worldwide brand and there's
there's like diehards who would like
move out Elian and two seconds I believe
that I believe that I have
sight prompters we've had a situation
people coming in and then once you let
them go then you're like they got okay
more please
we uprooted them we enabled we feel
really that's fair it's been scared to
like fish out that's fair there's two
ways to handle that one you over
communicate that upfront to you do what
I do which is you give egregious
severance is to make yourself feel
better we did something a Boehner where
I was like trying to let the company do
its thing and they fired somebody and I
[ __ ] hated the way they did it I
literally [ __ ] PayPal the guy ton of
my own personal money and then I told
them and they were [ __ ] pissed HR and
Finance and I was like cool why don't
you start paying attention how I want it
because every time I watch you guys do
it I'm gonna do this it is a little
crazy I like that story
my admins lost their mind like this
guy's on some because they see
everything they're like all right this
guy's playing it like me you know it's
one of those like when you think you've
seen everything and you're like what is
this guy doing I'm making a [ __ ]
point so what I'm doing yeah where you
at it with tick-tock how much are you
posting how much one more listen to me
because you guys already won on this for
a day all you're doing last time a year
ago was buying up underpriced real
estate and you were doing that on
Instagram when it was already four or
five years into the knowledge that
Beverly Hills or Malibu or Manhattan was
gonna be good he just bought Manhattan
in 1954 instead of 1898
tick tock is 1898 good try more I mean
it because you can't get that moment
back you can't buy facebook pre IPO back
you could buy it when it was $20 on Wall
Street but that was already not $3 like
I got it and we're feeling right now
through you can see you couldn't see it
I mean it's crazy dude I'm telling you I
know what I'm talking this is the one
thing that will keep me relevant until
dead I understand under priced organ
attention of the consumers of the world
wildly better than most people on earth
I keep saying it loud and Linkedin for
multiple like you like you've got to
post on LinkedIn four times a day it'll
work
these it's free reach I don't know what
to say there's nothing more and this is
actually unbelievable timing
I had Brandon who runs Wine Library so
we have this wine Tech's thing it's
really working and so obviously I feel
very confident our digital capabilities
to grow the list I'm like you know I'm
always checking myself I'm like I don't
know what's going on with traditional
costs New York Times was one of the
biggest ways I've built my dad's
business
nationally your cabs ads on Wednesday
stay once I yep on Wednesdays in the
dining section national dining section
full page ad wine library huge I'm like
okay that used to be $42,000 for a
full-page ad I bet it's like 20,000 I
wonder I should run one just to really
have any feel whatsoever to how print
does in 2020 I'm like branding called
The Times find out how much it cost he
calls him back yesterday he's like hey I
got the price thing I'm like all right I
was like excited I was like how much is
it he's like 46,000 I like literally
stub leaked in Chicago yes two days I
got like Whitman it Scott it's got up
10% he's like yeah these [ __ ] how the
[ __ ] is a full-page print add up 10% in
cost from 1998 when there was no
internet to have your attention anyway
nonetheless tick-tock four times a day
it will be love yeah I mean that's more
I love real life I love real life I'll
give you another one you want to really
get value out of vents spend the extra
money to do something crazy that
everybody wants to take a photo with you
see where I'm going
spend like an X now its break-even
charge a little more and then buy a
$4,000 like 800 foot foot
I bet you because it's breathing you're
smart so like the number one thing that
I love about real life is the Instagram
photo because now you're taking 300
people and they're building you the
awareness up to 6,000 people and if you
give them the ammo for the ridiculous
photo that's why I keep coming back so
if I'm right now I'm doing this is like
a cytosol so if I'm trying to I ask got
some feedback sensor if I don't
necessarily want to be a brand is it
better to create like a company brand or
create some kind of a character did you
want it real quick do you want to speak
anything else it's relieving that was my
biggest question yeah unbelievably which
is part of why I'm gonna go so do me a
favor do me a favor do me a favor on
that like it the one of the proud I'm
very good at doing what comes natural to
me at a forty not a ten but I was I was
also very good at what didn't come
natural to me to do at a zero so I
failed school like I was I've come to
learn I was more than smart enough to
probably get C's but I got FS I was
really good at completely punting
something I wasn't good at the proudest
thing that ever happened in my life at
this point from a personal standpoint
forget about kids and some of that was
when I recognized that thirty eight and
a half that I needed to get serious
about my health the fact that I then
turned that into not what I first
thought in the plane which is that forty
I'll get serious on my 40th birthday
I'll start and then within two hours of
that flight started literally the next
day it's kind of what I want to inspire
you to do which is the only way this
good moment means anything is if you
actually put it directly into practice
even though it doesn't come natural you
know cuz you're doing what comes natural
so give that some thought like really
push whatever tricks you to do it you
know good awesome
I hope you enjoyed the rest of the day
if you don't want to be the personal
brand right right I'm a little limited
right now of course what the question is
what brand do you built is that what
you're asking
yeah I'm just curious is it is do I
start branding like as a company or I've
thought about just kind of creating some
kind of a character what kind of talk I
like it what kind of KISS here you know
like a Western title like you character
you acting as an animation hiring
somebody person or animation yeah
animation I love because Mickey Mouse is
a lot easier to control than Susan
Sarandon you know what I mean yeah so
I'm a big fan of animation like a big
one and I actually think it's one of the
big white spaces and in social marketing
right now like I'm probably gonna create
a augmented reality character that's
going to start showing up in all my
content it's a big conversation we're
having right now and then he'll be we're
just like you where's goosebumps he'll
be wearing like my virtual dog that
always barks when people do dumb [ __ ]
and then everybody's gonna think it's
cool and I myself stickers and plush
toys and Barka Barka and then like
feedback of their question if I was
gonna do some kind of talk to me where
we're at right now in the side hustle
you've made stuff yeah Stefan's
introduction girly yeah but we have it
and who's we a theoretical we were your
partners no I have it's my wife and I
and then psy hired somebody to help me
kind of navigate
the fashion industry side hustle and she
has a lot of experience with this type
of fabrics this type of stuff design and
everything also so just rang yeah get
off the ground
yeah I'm gonna make this very simple
your job is so simple an extremely hard
you have to make people aware of it and
compel them to buy it right by you're
gonna sell it on your own website yeah
so right away that has extra friction
that a lot of people right now don't
want right because this is why Amazon in
other places like like people don't want
to put their credit card at the [ __ ]
it's like like even though the of
automatic fill out like this is where
like people don't understand how
powerful conveniences that's why the
Apple credit card thing is really
interesting to me like it's just
friction like I would be more likely to
buy your product if I could just like
not fill out anything and that's like
where this is all going right so anyway
nonetheless you have to build brand the
reason I get obsessed with LinkedIn and
tik-tok is you don't have unlimited
funds so you need to be most efficient
there's two ways to do it one you win on
art or you win on math right math is you
you had the kind of background I'm
making I'm making up this scenario you
come from financial services so you're
grounded in math and you become
incredible at Facebook and Instagram
arbitrage and your CAC is better is
under your LTV and you're just crushing
it you're one of those guys right it
doesn't even matter about that much
about the marketing it's just that
you're so good at buying the ads and
it's converting so well and you're not
underwater and you're happy or you're in
the art stuff which is like you
understand how to make the creative that
actually gets people like Dollar Shave
Club was an execution of art not of math
even though is a classic DTC brain that
is completely built on normally being
reliant on math so this is why I think
people will forever follow me because if
they keep just doing what I'm doing and
later their own self-awareness on it to
know which part they can and can't do
it's great that you know that like
you've decided for yourself maybe
because of your other biz
your job or maybe just who you are as a
human I don't want to be the front the
good news is that is not a requirement
at all
there are far more brands that are
winning than personal brands so it's
more common for that
I think influencer marketing is a beast
for you like I don't think people
understand how apparel really works like
you're one person deciding to wear it
away from doing more for your business
than 9-thousand other executions so I
think that's a very heavy place to focus
on but a lot of the rest of what 4ds was
about has laid out for you the game had
Bertha Garrett thank you and thank you
for your staff I was scheduled twice in
LA so Nick and Arjun made it often so
let's say yep purchase or Wine Library
today and Sasha had run it old-school
way yes for 40 years
yes and you purchased it today yes what
would you do to get the word out that
there's new ownership not necessarily
understood but word out for acquiring
talent internally or external clients
external clients BOE understudy and in
California yep
and I assume the business based on 40
years why you brought up Sasha is and at
that level has strictly built been a
hardcore grindin word-of-mouth business
for 40 years understood was hardcore
grinding he has a showroom notice
exactly that's that's up 40 years and
three million looks like yeah that's
what I do I understand so he has a short
we have a short presence and yeah
Northern California doesn't work
everywhere but but in Northern
California does well what do you think
your value prop is in in Northern
California or just California in general
California in general California in
general mix the ground service hike to
anywhere in California okay and but I
assume everybody telephone you can do
that too
next a ground know why because they're
not in there most of their head office
they're moving out of California because
just the cost of doing business in
California yeah
California yeah yeah yeah so and then
face the face you actually see a face to
face you can call us from a customer
service standpoint you can actually
reach a customer service person directly
right away and then also face the face
you can actually see your rep do a
couple things I would start a podcast
around supplies and I'm not kidding I'm
a big buyer a very narrow very small
very niche podcasts and I would invite
the runners of the companies to be
guests to talk about their careers
I'm not kidding and I would be the host
of this show and I would invite the
executives on the show to talk about
life by doing that you become you gain
the leverage on brand of becoming the
place of authority and all you're doing
is interviewing your actual potential
customers and making them feel famous
which then builds awareness if you
emailed the nine hundred clients that
you know who you're trying to get right
correct if you email them and said hey
it's me I want your business that's one
thing if you emailed them and said hey I
have something called the Joe and in I
noticed that you've been the 7 year head
at Canon you know amazing and so we'd
love to have you on the show to talk
about life nerd culture what's going on
in the industry your personal career
you'll never get anybody to reply in the
first one you'll get half of them
applying a second one I would do that I
would then do what I do with dailyvee
and my podcast I would have that
interview then I would cut it up in a
Prost production world and I would run
ads on LinkedIn of snippets from other
people for them to see it yeah because
LinkedIn is huge in terms of building
things your LinkedIn is your world
you're on LinkedIn ads against employees
and engineers of the companies are
trying to reach with the content being
something smart that one of the people
said on your show
coming from the account that is you or
your business game over
you build a business
taewin LinkedIn ads against prospective
correct companies with content would not
came from commercials with CNBC content
not infomercial by my program content
got it
no call to action because everything
else he's doing is a sales organization
he's a sales organization everything he
has in place is a sales organization
whenever he has is sales this is
building brand once we get face to face
we close probably 75% in time I would
art vaynermedia is the fastest growing
revenue agency in the world I would
argue that we are in the bottom 1% of
worst new business processes we
legitimately don't know how to do new
business that's how much top of the
funnel brand we have that just people
hand us business the companies in the
world that only do our piece and only
have procurement literally hand this to
business because the top of the funnel
brand and then the best part true word
of mouth to the people that have
actually worked with us steak and sizzle
only two things are gonna be left the
actual product and the variable within
it and the ability to communicate and
the ability to communicate is more
powerful than a product because
oftentimes the product has already been
told you of its quality based on the
communication you've been told you've
been told it's the best burger you even
told it's the best handbag why does have
$98,000 it's the best really because if
I take that burka off its name and give
you the same thing it's 800 bucks brand
along a similar process you just did of
diagnosing and through it laughter maybe
so that the company's called Ravager
Sasha client we you know last year about
a hundred thousand leads converted to
two thousand starts so the revenue
generation happens when the student
starts yep and over the lifetime of that
student we get about a hundred thousand
dollars so we're going to get those
starts our business challenge today it's
a no have you spoken to those
ninety-eight thousand people in love way
and he called them and asked him why
didn't do it we've done a lead
conversion failure study mm mm right
yeah I'm not so good to two percent
conversion rate right yeah understood
yeah how many of the ninety eight
thousand have you actually had a
conversation with what you've got tell
you probably for real for real don't
look give it to me
sixty percent contact Ray so there's
been at least one contact over the phone
but like you know asking them wide not
oh okay so yeah those whole scheme of
those twenty four thousand we know they
didn't convert because of one or two
issues yeah because we have turning
locations across the country and they
didn't want to relocate so relocation is
the number one reason
stop running add stuff go into those
agents into those regions
let's start point number one right yeah
how are you guys acquiring leads
facebooking me through job boards
understood so indeed
yeah Akshay yellow your classic job
boards we don't do Google or Facebook
today really it is the reason why it's
great I'm glad I'm glad because it's
great those are greatly Jen's cuz it's
intent-based but if we can focus on
being regional with our lead gen from
Google and Facebook environment it gets
real good yeah yeah so one thing is to
stop in those regions where we just
don't get much if you can I'm not
familiar enough with the job boards
regionality capability yeah and part of
the struggle trying to figure out is you
know when you're in an operation you
know you're obviously testing and
learning all the time but pulling back
from job boards cuz it's work so well
it's fueled our growth right now you're
talking about why everybody goes out of
business the number one reason people go
out of business is the romantic about
the thing that got them there yep I
understand that yeah and that and then
I'm building the brand this podcast
thing it's real for you because you
could just mark them - yep you know how
everybody's like oh my company's got a
purpose and we're doing things for like
you know how every but that's you know
now we've got to all be woke and amazing
people so every [ __ ] startup is like
we give back a dollar to the rainforest
or we really give a [ __ ] about snails
and Portugal or like like we care about
people with hangnails like everyone's
got to have something I actually think
the right way to do that is to actually
have a Content arm of every business
that acts like a complete church and
state editorial the predict that in 15
years every single business will have an
editor-in-chief who cannot be touched by
anybody if you had a Content arm that
had no intent of it being a top of the
foot my friends the reason I believe I
win is because when I make content there
is absolutely no thought of how it
trickles down to these moments
yeah that's the punchline the
performance it's just content a former
employee tweeted out yesterday that
there is no such thing as free content
and somebody jump didn't like because
this person has always given me good
accolades that I've helped them and like
what about Gary B and this person was
like even him and I laughed I was like
you didn't hang out long enough to
actually get it yeah of course there's
something that happens but it's but I
know I know who I am as a human I know
when I make a video I know what's
happening people understand that that's
actually the punchline
if you can stay disciplined and actually
try to bring entertainment value and
information value to every employee
you'll get business because people are
gonna want to be on your [ __ ] podcast
after a year mark my words yours has
more you know more like there's a lot
more shows for like going into the
workplace HR millennial workers now
you're you're in the game of being best
you have to do what these guys did on
Instagram Instagram it was that scale a
year ago enough scale that if them
getting all these results they were good
at it now I'm trying to get them to get
what he has was just like tick tock you
don't have to be good at it just go hard
yeah cuz there's more of a bi there he's
gonna win just on actually creating it
he only needs 47 people listening to his
podcast for it didn't change his
business it's cool this is why I love
b2b marketing hila generally there's no
joke cuz you guys are gonna see business
like maybe like he actually needs the
[ __ ] four hundred people actively
listening for it to double his business
overnight actually need ten clients that
I could double my business totally
no seriously and it works for all of us
even b2c like you could start the ice
cream shop I was I was thinking about
that so
so after bought out my partner yeah just
had to change
Brandon Shore I was like packaging and
you know you have to do things that yeah
you had to do the things you wanted to
do all along I guess and there's also a
fear factor to it we are I didn't want
to do anything and
make mistakes so it's kind of surprising
to me that were as good as we are
without any friend you know what is it
puff this is exciting task is it is it
just a great product it's I know it's
your baby I get it but what do you think
it's yeah that happens you know no but
it's not it's it's not saying that
that's great okay I know that it's you
know so now I'm at the point now where I
have to raise the brand awareness we are
going into e-commerce I don't want to
start it unless you know we have the
sales going there so you know I'm sort
of starting in square one
yeah you are yeah that's great is it you
know why it's great you have no choice
right but like for example like tick
tock II know it's a younger audience yes
that's not necessarily the people that
are you know it's the moms it's the you
know well let's talk about a couple
things
one thing that you should know is that
teenage girls influenced mom decisions
of buying products in the home at a
level that we've never seen so one viral
video so let's talk about Lacroix
Lacroix sparkling water was completely a
phenomenon of Instagram girls which then
led to the moms I would argue the best
thing that could happen to you is
virality and tick tock not ma blogger
but as far as creating that content does
that all come for me I mean I sort you
the human or you the executive who
empowers something to happen for the
brand to do it I guess yeah yes it does
that's right yeah you have to be
educated enough to make the right hire
this is what I always yell out in my
conferences you know do my talk there's
always this great moment when I'm in
that kind of talk where I'm like I get
the whole conservative crew or people
that haven't done it like super onboard
and then I'm like then I switch it on
him like but now I know what you're
thinking now that I've got you up over
the last 20 minutes you're about to hire
your niece you're about to hire the
cliche 23 year old from school because
you think they get it if you don't have
the ability to judge that person you're
vulnerable my favorite thing is I can do
every job here I can't do it well like I
can't do any of the jobs at
or well but I know them all I can
definitely judge it and that's super
important when you own a business yes
for sure so if I'm trying to find
somebody to post on tik-tok let's say to
create content great hey let me give you
a real insight that I used to I only
said it once publicly I'm gonna say it
again now I'm gonna say it a lot more I
really really really want you to
download tik-tok I do
great and I really really really want
you to spend five full hours over the
next 30 days next 60 days I'm just
consuming it you will be blown away by
how that little exercise will make you
far more knowledgeable you'll just have
context yeah like why are they all doing
that dance what but you're gonna first
you're gonna say man god what society do
we live in where every eleven-year-old
talks about sex a lot more than I ever
thought like you start doing all those
things but like you'll learn you'll have
a much better shot of making a judgement
but yes no but as far as like then who
do you you're trying to find high or
somebody that to help create that
content that understands tick-tock yeah
I'm say that the seventeen-year-old I'm
40 40 that's notice how I've learned it
I was about I said 40 49 times [ __ ] and
I got couple more hours
it's the biggest misconception of all
time like we do such typecasting I hate
that like people that understand and
Latino consumer don't have to be Latino
and vice versa there's plenty Latinos
that understand Caucasian mindset you
need somebody who's capable and that
doesn't mean a 17 year old to your point
it's far more likely that it is right
now but what I love about the five hours
is I mean you I gotta tell you it's so
fun life like if you came back if I got
an email from you in nine months and it
said you will not believe this before I
started reading it I'm like she's the
one making the tick-tock like you just
never know that are us to say this
thesis is what brought me to Gary Vee it
was 34 years old before I made a Content
ID oh I was running a retail store I
didn't think I was a personality I
didn't move to LA and wait tables to be
on TV you know no one to you might be
the person
you just might it seems for in this [ __ ]
but after you get five hours of it
you're like huh you just kind of make
one like you you it's the cliche story
you're like sitting there you're
thinking back to this exact moment
you're like what I have to lose we have
no followers anyway you do some sort of
funny thing with the there's a huge
trend where people pour soda in or
beverages into a cop against this one
song until it overflows
you might just be like I'm gonna do that
with our ice cream sure enough this is
why tick tock special you do that on
YouTube Twitter Facebook or Instagram
nothing happens but because there's free
organic views on tick-tock you do that
and the right tick-tock terse sees it
and does their own version of it and you
wake up in a week and you're like Gary
is a [ __ ] genius yeah that's a real
that's that's completely the way tick
tock like literally so drew makes
awesome content I posted I was at Costco
that [ __ ] like chickens coming out of
the oven I got 400 as place this will go
and this is like the most kombucha cow
she's a monster and all those chickens
are unbranded if you did that with your
ice cream like that visual that much
awareness this is how it works
you know when when that Texas kid goes
to an h-e-b after you get distribution
and they're like pissed that they're
there with their mom at the supermarket
because after softball practice but they
saw that tick tock and they see their
mom mom get that yeah that's real life
all my friends who were making fun of me
about my tick tock propaganda all have
gotten really quiet because if they've
been with me in the last three weeks
they've watched an eight-year-old run up
to me and lose their mind and take a
selfie and every time they look at me
like tick tock Jerry you worry about the
perfect demo coming up tick tock as wild
it's kind of all over the West you just
say [ __ ] go for it all I'm trying to
reach every person on earth right so I
don't the demo is somebody who's alive
you know what about us though do we want
to reach everybody there's a lot of
course you do
they'll self-select out of your [ __ ] you
know many people hate me because I curse
doesn't mean I'm not trying to get him
building a personal brand yes assuming
baseline yep
what do you recommend self-awareness of
how you best enjoy communicating and
that allows you to make the most content
written word audio or video starts there
and then once you've done that sense of
self assessment let's say it's written
great video yep then you make at scale
and if yeah and if you're not able to
sign up for vein or talent and do it on
your phone just do it I know I do yep
yes every day doing dominant post-it I
did it for 80 years I'd have a single
person on my team and you poster so you
wake up every morning do a video a rope
meets on Twitter just put it on Twitter
and I had a flip cam remember those
things just like set it up we like it
all right it all starts the same way
right it's all the same [ __ ] right oh we
don't have the amps and the guitars to
be like you guys I'm like data and
either they were GarageBand made a
shitty thing they bought at a garage
sale and went to guitar store we don't
have the I can't be like Steven
Spielberg Steven Spielberg got a shitty
[ __ ] camera and made background
movies like it's all the same [ __ ] you
don't need an equinox membership to work
out you can go outside and deal does
that kind of rhythm jump on [ __ ]
buildings or something I don't know
you know everybody uses an excuse if you
couldn't write you've won everything on
your phone go right go right your point
of view on the current job market to
Millennials on LinkedIn right now is a
blog post right now actually don't I
want to add that I want to add that the
four DS I want to add to four DS a
forced moment of 15 minutes for people
that actually make a piece of content on
the spot
especially on the two that are organic
reach linked it in tick-tock you know
Jeff do you spend doing personal content
development out of your what do you
think you - what you got how much time
do I write everything every single tweet
you see I wrote that every single piece
of copy all the written words under an
Instagram post that's me I post every
single Instagram post and you love that
think about the fact that I'm a think
about yeah just think about 40
yeah just like think about 40 minutes
though like there's not a yeah except
nobody's no executives doing that it is
the single most important thing in the
world
Communications the only thing left
everything else is getting commoditized
how about events you talked about events
for them yeah I think you start with the
podcast cuz it gives you permission to
do events once you have 400 listeners
when you promote your own event on the
podcast and then 12 people RSVP you're
like holy [ __ ] people are listening
start with the podcast do that it will
work put that flag in the ground first
cold email you know fun it's gonna be to
fly home and cold email the 50 people
that you dream wish that knew who you
wish that they knew who you are and now
the email says I'd love to have you on
our podcast you're gonna get yeses it's
crazy we did that yeah even just dams on
us here and we're down here for us yeah
cuz that's more your world his version
of that is linked in messages for sure
yeah alright yeah